oh
11 Hunter
I shot it suspect I'm shot I start medic
newly released body camera video shows a
North Carolina police officer shot in
the line of duty by a 14 year old boy
with a lengthy criminal record
it happened in Charlotte North Carolina
on December 27th of last year just
before seven o'clock that morning a
9-1-1 call came in about a Suspect with
a weapon breaking into someone's car
I'll tell you my apartment once a guy
with all a feast of trying to stole my
car and she was pointing me he was
trying to kill me the caller described
the suspect to dispatch and said he was
armed with a pistol okay so he pointed
the gun at you is that right yes okay so
when you confronted him he pointed the
gun at you yes yes
he put the gun in my head officer Elliot
Whitley a 10-year veteran of the
Charlotte Mecklenburg Police Department
was the Second Officer to arrive on the
scene
let me see your hands
when the suspect outran the first
officer Whitley began chasing him
calling for the boy to get to the ground
man I'm not playing with you body camera
video shows Whitley chasing the boy
through the apartment complex for nearly
30 seconds
that's when the 14 year old pulls his
own weapon and Fires at Whitley he
quickly responds firing back at the
suspect more than a dozen times
fuck
1100
I shot it suspect I'm shot I start
medical as emergency responders make
their way to the scene other officers
work to arrest the suspect
yeah yeah okay
at this point in the video Whitley
removes his shirt so the camera is
partially covered
officer has been shot the 14 year old
suspect is later arrested and charged
with assault with a deadly weapon
inflicting Serious injury because he's
under 18 years old police have not yet
released his name they do say the boy
had more than 50 charges prior to this
incident including motor vehicle theft
breaking and entering and possession of
a controlled substance he's been in
custody since the shooting officials say
Whitley was shot in the shoulder and
treated for non-life-threatening
injuries while Whitley is expected to
make a full recovery the bullet was not
removed from his shoulder
11 Hunter
I shot it suspect I'm shot I start medic
the Charlotte Mecklenburg Police
Department completed an investigation
into the officer-involved shooting and
determined Whitley's actions were
Justified for the latest developments in
this case and all things True Crime stay
with long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie